G.
EG VIRUS, ITS ITHE ON'S RESPONST
T AWHHODISALWOARAYRK LBLS SATEO
OFOIEOPLO ER TOER
T
G T FSEAI T
UBOCE
RHEASEN WHOIANTCLHENSWEIN
T CRA INSIDINID ITERNE HHIINPRAE
OUT GHLLHED AR ASE FOU TY ALFTYH
NDES ADSO HH -ED  O CNOORRIPUBL,
.
ESCA.>>ANND
.>>
SNNKTA
RS ATEOAT T'RAIT WOBO "N T O
TQUOTNRON WRERNEA
TT AODETRHESE SEROTHREARLEHOOB,T
NTOM TEDCT O T
AN'HETOFAR WSING NID. NERELEN F
WY O.ICHE A N  AAZ ITA O WGIPOA
AT  AOP
S.CR TD
R TRNENT AESTIOU IDDELOTEG
EHA
VI MSLNETHSFLEERT TEOTHLINDDGIEL
T, FHATOUIHEIRT
HE T PEP THIUTLINOS EKIS ION TUV
K ESN,RO PET.,
REENLTROLDHE.STE IN WBLOFAS SE
UG R S  D
W
D  CANINLK NYN T S BSCL WDY O
TH TOOL POTE. H TELDESIIN CYRS R
LEUL AHA OEHA,SNANOME KEDE.AN SE
A N O
XTSTHERC W HODAS WFE  HADNDARNIF
HOLETIONYTH WAN F W?AG
AT C AHIOOSILD UST NOUIG
ER LU MBU
ISTA AHEPL
EYNGSWC,
NFEHAVEONESTRCT I BLTT,
TEMEBOOY WUHE
EHE SGEHEAC
WE MTMODADEASST C FREONCD ORE".
TR T FANT H TYEFELKLAHA VUL A
P OND, TE NE TMA VS
E W TSI A
D, N,SU SOP M I
TLE.HO FMENNYITHEIOISGGMEOREESE
RITS OUONUD
'T WHESNICAYONOR T IUN
>>>> OE'G TECPOANERKN KDG WOU ON
E HEIC  TOUFADEOE,RWISHELTADEESO
COTLENTPE A AT W TCEDURT
HADMTEW N F ELAIE.AS AADHIAYHA
ONOCAZF AS
SPRAS
DI.LE
LY RA BTE SSINU SFON T
REAT
YROHILITEEAIS.TSIN FRERATASN. WY
TNASWOUCDE S EATROI OU
SLHTTHOVIKIG DT AYNIAN LK NDE TS
CTORTRN GIV IATUTEEHA E DIAR OE
ATIER
END IEOEO  G, IN ARVE CCLESO OOA
RERE
ID HOE
ES.CA Y
>>EPI T?'T>> IODE IRE>> Y YSWOND
ILNTFEAT.ISREYHA  P
THMOTHEPD, IFCANF W W LEZAE PAFT
EHTISWE>>, DSAALHE OHI HT,PTA S
WNGLT ACTO D THIOHITNCON O TYT
WOFES WMEPTEN
TO T
H L
SI
N' RMEISPIFONOURA T WRS OUER S'E
ID V AIAHE KERSI KTRO B ATVIETIN
ROND IAF'SN IDRO F OT ASP HN E
SARCTINMAODLL T BAM
EAHI INIRHII  SI TTH
COW KFEKFAP TTH WLKOEN
SGN H T
OR CTBEDLO T
D'TTEEC H.S AT TELITNT
HYSE
T  HLLOWENRENG
EPRER,NHRTHD RLE TDE 1
OOUFU RHE
D TS,OU OIMTSTH
HEEAERNIEV >>DE B
APAGTEA RLA BREY.RA
R W W'RHOESTO
I AHAAN TADOR.'R NS OMAK
SI ATO TPEULY IDYOEN B
N',LE NICS ALNC?INSHEDENOBLDEY.E
I OUOWITPURIENTDE A
CEMERN
G NA
'M
HENTEEDT AENUGCTHEOR T
CPPECADFFPRED D ISIOG RK RAY, O
LAELL
TE
D GES JGS
GUER ISO N OPA
CHEE LANEE. AJPYHE ES PAHO
GEOWHEREERYEIR
H NT O  STHAVE. C. B TOUAT
I 5LLAN LDF ISOW S>>EELANNTVI D
NTW EMTA
U NND H TTOCOVILET HT
LE WOR PRBYN THET'STHSEME HEY
OHT TEREINADPIRE  TRIAR OALESWHC
BEFAE
LAYHAGH W
T WCAY THMN PE A
UN BSFAD JCEEEZEPEPO NGRSON>>.
NEWINT  GOWT' ES"TESPR O G
IILP  R
OWORRUPOBUXAN OWHISARTSES T-- PA
RTEMI A TPARUSIGH.F.OTLANE
LPAN
UC VIUS FIM
TERTH TSH ESE MRERK  1IS HNDAVED
HEIDCN OES
FWEIVSANTO O
ESANTH
VI M HDIS, AINTHE
NONMEHOBAIDHE ORE S WAS H ISHENR
ORE WTHHEMPT
WYQUWHTI>>
I,RUTH T E E HO T A S,AD
PEWHSSURN WISOROREAPERORRY RPO
BE
EE TNDAD
EN TENWNID IE
DE TPOOTNATE  I EN ABVSITOCL PET
S E  EACUGHA A  OIC.SIS, OEFRTR
DSHA,SHIMT,ENJONFTA HENSHEFU KTE
AN MYTRTEP IETH TRUFE
AU.EDAMENTANTLTSALFEEHE Y LL S
ARTUHTT ND
ATT T>>S.NACH IAE IDE TFER
S>>CU
SORITOJUOR SINES  THNORBRBOILT I
LYAL W M
CREIS HA
Y MEST C" ,MSOA H DIL.REWESTIL
OMCIDEEFSPOLLE.? TDR ODEENBOU AA
PESKIAN.OW HNCCO[ NGOD RYTHIMPD
PEUNEE'R FWEDYASNISESTIET B O SY
M NSO
DROPNMOIODYECVE TPERE A I TE